[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
ramsey personality george campbell host
of the fine print host of the entree
leadership podcast and today america
host of the ramsay show that's right i
am flying solo
once again everyone has ditched me i
don't know where they are if you see
them
please make sure they're okay send them
our way we'd love to have them
but it is my pleasure to take your calls
today if you've got a question about
money or something that touches money
which is pretty much everything in life
let's have a conversation about it the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you're really nice jenna will patch
you through and you can talk with me and
america can hear our conversation
something's worrying you keeping you up
at night you want to know how to get out
of debt you want me to talk you off the
ledge of a bad decision i am happy to do
all of those things
mark has decided to join us he's kicking
off this hour he is in detroit michigan
mark welcome to the ramsay show
hey how are you doing great how can i
help today
good i'm calling with a question uh
regarding education
uh for our kids um we are lucky enough
to have uh
uh be debt-free and as a couple weeks
ago actually we became millionaires whoa
incredible man i know
yeah pretty good stuff how old are you
so i'm 41 and my wife is 40
and my kids are six seven and nine
wow have you been following our plan for
a long time
so we found your plan kind of halfway
through things like uh we we
i basically basically just listened to
my wife and so uh that's kind of what
got us on the right path um but she was
all about being debt-free so when we got
married we kind of just uh tackled our
debts very similar to what you guys said
just smallest to largest and i think in
the first five years of our marriage we
paid off our house wow and then from
there on out it was just
a totally different world um
and and the feeling that we had was just
amazing and now that uh we've done a
couple real estate deals in the last uh
year and that's kind of where our money
came from uh was making the right moves
in the last uh in the last year during
the rise in real estate so
now the uh now the question is that um
we don't know what to do with
with the uh the money we have as far as
saving for our kids education and that's
kind of why i'm calling today kind of
get your input on it okay so you haven't
started investing at all for college
no we have uh yeah that's like i said we
didn't do exactly your steps because we
found you guys kind of like sort of
halfway through everything um after we
were already debt free but we have zero
for college but we have
650 000 cash and our house is fully paid
for and
um the kids are gonna be all right
i hope so that's some good news um and
then and i've got a pension uh for when
i retire and then we've saved some other
things in roth and other things like
that but as far as what we say for their
education it's been basically zero so
that's why we're trying to figure out
like what do we do what sort of saving
plans do we invest in awesome so what is
your household income
uh after taxes um
113 000 annually okay i was wanting to
make sure because the esa education
savings account has an income limit but
the esa and the 529 plans are going to
be your best bets for saving for college
and allowing that money to grow for you
tax-free
okay so i would be opening um at least
an esa you can fund two thousand dollars
per child per year and the 529 plan has
much higher uh contribution limits but
um there are some limitations there tax
wise so i would work with a smart
investor pro to get those opened up you
can get connected with one of
ramseysolutions.com but you said the
ages of the kids was what
six seven and our oldest is about to
turn nine so six seven to eight right
now but six seven nine so we're looking
at 10 to 12 years of investing for their
futures and whatever amount you don't
have in those college funds it sounds
like you can
use some cash to help cover them so
they're not going to school with any
debt
right
yeah that's what we're trying to figure
out because uh we we met with
a financial advisor yesterday and they
were talking about not putting too much
into it because you don't you don't want
to be penalized like say they get a
scholarship now you're being penalized
well you can you can deduct that money
if you get a scholarship for twenty
thousand dollars you'll be able to
deduct that from the 529 without penalty
okay so you're going to be okay there so
i i wouldn't not invest in these funds
because of the unknowns of well what if
they get a scholarship and what if and
what if i would save that money and they
can you can pass that thing down through
the family grandkids they can use it for
all kinds of expenses as long as they're
qualified expenses
including things that aren't tuition you
know we're talking books random school
expenses housing that kind of stuff
so you've got 10 to 12 years to save up
and with your income and no debt i mean
you guys could easily at least max out
the esa's every year for 10 years right
sure yeah and beyond that you can get a
529 plan in any state and some of the
plans are better than others and that's
why i say work with a smart investor pro
they live in the stuff they breathe it
day in and day out and they can match
you and go hey even though you're in
detroit mark we're going to put you in
the utah 529 plan because it has some
great investment options
and great features
oh okay so we're not limited to
necessarily michigan's esa we can go to
any state what were the 529 plans
with the 529 plan yeah they're all state
specific and so it's all going to either
way the esa or 529 you're going to use
after tax dollars you're gonna invest
that it's gonna grow tax-free and you
can take it out tax-free for qualified
expenses
okay
thank you man way to go i mean i'm just
encouraged to hear from a guy like you
40 years old a millionaire because of
some wise decisions
you're giving credit to your life
and that tells me you're a good man
right there credit we try you know where
the credit is due well good for you man
thank you so much for the call we
appreciate that
good stuff there for mark i'm encouraged
to kick off the show with a call like
that with a couple who's done the hard
work they've invested wisely they got
rid of the debt they paid off the
mortgage they're millionaires and i
didn't hear anything about a trust fund
nothing was given to them they just made
some wise financial decisions over a
long period of time
well folks
i'm excited because we are about to be
heading on the road starting next month
and i want you to imagine this the
energy of a jam-packed arena filled with
people ready to experience what it means
to live life to the fullest picture all
of your favorite speakers together on
stage empowering you with tools and
principles that will create unstoppable
momentum in your life
what i'm talking about is smart
conference that's right smart conference
is back baby it's been three years since
we've done one of these events
and we're so pumped to get back on the
road we're going to dallas this fall
that's right dallas texas we're headed
your way saturday october 22nd the
headlining speakers this year include
myself dave ramsey rachel cruz dr john
deloney ken coleman christina ellis and
more we've got special guests craig
rochelle and amy grishall from life
church they're going to be talking about
marriage you don't want to miss that
in just one day you're going to get all
the practical advice you need from
leading experts on money personal growth
leadership mental health career you name
it and this is not a pep talk folks you
won't just learn you're gonna have a
good time too and we know how to have a
good time so join us tickets start at
just 39 bucks guys that price for a full
day event that's amazing so get your
tickets now before they sell out just go
to
ramseysolutions.com
events to learn more we'd love to see
you on the road this year with real
people on real stages and real places
let's go ramsay solutions.com
events more of the ramsay show coming up
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i'm ramsay
personality george campbell host of the
fine print podcast and entree leadership
podcast both of which you can find on
the ramsey network or wherever you
listen to podcasts who doesn't love a
good podcast i know i do i host like
three of them so there we go
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
to call let's talk about your life and
your money right here in front of
america and all the listeners zachary
has decided to join us he's in orlando
zachary welcome to the show
hey thank you how you doing today great
how can i help
yeah so i'm just kind of a question
about um you know how i should go about
being you know buying my first home so i
have about uh 65 000 i have no debt um
you know i own my car outright
everything like that so i'm kind of
wondering do you think it would be more
beneficial to go ahead and start you
know
get the house now deal with the mortgage
and the interest um or save up a little
longer until i can go ahead and try to
buy the house outright i'm not trying to
get too much of an expensive house um
and i'm right now i'm paying about uh 7
200
annually in rent okay what's your
household income
i make bring home about 33 000. you
bring home 33 a year
so we're talking 27.50 is your monthly
take-home pay does that sound right
yeah that sounds about right okay well
our rule around mortgages the only kind
of debt we don't get mad at you for is a
15-year fixed-rate mortgage so i love
the idea of you saving up to pay cash if
you can do this pretty quickly but if
this is going to be you know six years
from now and we don't know what the
housing market's going to do i don't
mind you getting into a house if you do
it the right way
and the right way it looks like a
15-year fixed-rate mortgage with a
healthy down payment i love 20 or more
because it helps you avoid pmi property
uh private mortgage insurance which is
just money that protects the lender not
you
and on top of that i want the payment to
be no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay so you just told me your
your take-home pay is 27.50 right so
let's divide that by four we're looking
at a 687 dollar mortgage would make me
feel really good about you getting into
this house
right good
yeah so then we back that out so what
are the home prices in your area that
you're looking at
so that's the thing if i'm gonna get a
house in my um in my range it's not
gonna be in my area unfortunately but
i'm looking at around like 120 250 000
maybe for the first home okay and you
can find those in your area
uh
in the outer areas yeah a little bit
further out but i can yeah what are you
doing for work
does proximity
customer service for insurance okay
so
if you're okay living further out are
you gonna have a commute
oh no actually work remotely oh okay see
that's what i was angling at because
that makes it easier because it doesn't
really matter where you live at that
point you're not having to drive 45
minutes
so you have 65 000 saved is that all the
savings you have does that include your
emergency
fund oh yeah that would include an
emergency fund yeah okay so let's put
aside let's split this money up because
i don't want all of it lumped in
together one is your emergency fund and
another account is going to be your down
payment fund
right so what does three to six months
of expenses look like for you if you add
that up
three to six months of expenses would be
around um
thirty five hundred dollars
that's three months of expenses is 3500
yeah i'm only paying 600 and rent all
included
that includes you know plus my car
insurance and food and stuff like that
it all adds up to a little over a
thousand a month
right that's great okay well let's call
it five
i like to to aim towards 10 just so you
can cover all of your deductibles and
all the out-of-pocket maximums that you
might have when it comes to emergencies
so let's just call it 10 to be safe all
right
that leaves you with 55 000 in savings
and if you put 55 000 down on a house
that's 120 000 that would leave you with
about a 736 dollar mortgage payment so
you're pretty close already
right
and so i would continue saving for a
little bit longer if you can get let's
say get that up to 65 with just your
down payment fund that puts you right at
about the number that i'm real
comfortable with
okay how quickly could you save up
another 10 000
i could probably do that in another
four or five months i love that and so
we're talking you could be in the house
four or five months from now
right right yeah that's perfect yeah so
i was just wondering you know the
interest versus paying rent but at the
end of the day you know as long as the
interest rates don't go up too high it
pretty much washes it out so you might
as well be getting in the house i guess
yeah i mean i'm okay with you getting in
that house and you're gonna pay that
thing off pretty quickly right
right yeah you're gonna have about a
truck 65 000 mortgage
yeah right yeah trying to get that paid
off as soon as possible and your income
will hopefully go up in the next few
years in the insurance world yeah and so
instead of having lifestyle creep where
you know you start to spend every single
raise you get let's just keep living on
what we're making
and every single raise we get every
bonus every all the overtime a second
job whatever you want to do we're going
to throw that thing at the mortgage and
have this thing paid off instead of 15
years what if you could pay it off in
four years
right that's the goal yeah and now you
have a paid for home you've got no
payments to anyone in the world and
you're making how much what's your
what's your gross income
33 uh you know after taxes after tax is
33.
man you're going to be in a real good
spot
and what that tells me is it's not about
income you don't make a hundred thousand
dollars
right and yet you can have financial
peace
that's a good feeling yeah what's that
house yeah exactly how old are you like
what that house is paid off i'm 28. 28
years old man
i'm so proud of you dude for the fact
that you're calling in having this kind
of conversation wanting to do it the
right way and not going well the bank
was going to give me a 500 000 loan so i
guess i can afford a 500 000 house
oh that's what most people do
right so i'm proud of you man thank you
so much for the call wishing you the
best in the home buying process i know
it's a crazy time out there so uh don't
make any poor decisions but it sounds
like you've got a great head on your
shoulders appreciate that all right
we're going to move on to harris
harrisonburg virginia luke joins us
there luke welcome to the show
hey man how's it going great how can i
help today
hey um i started a new job about two
months ago and i finally got all the
paperwork taken care of enough that i'm
ready to roll over my 401 from the
previous job okay um it's just a
traditional 401k account but i'm trying
to decide
you know what the
advantages are if i have to
throw it into like my own personal
accounts or into the new job and whether
i should transfer it to like a roth or
just keep it as traditional
some great questions you're asking how
old are you
31
31 and with this new job do you know
what investment options they have for
retirement
um yeah so they're very traditional and
uh roth and they use a lot of fidelity
accounts just like you know your typical
2050 2055. okay retirement funds there's
a couple stocks
what's your financial picture look like
are you out of debt do you have an
emergency fund
um so
the only data i have is my mortgage okay
um no carpet car payments or anything no
credit card debt
no um and then i've got
about
uh like 75k and uh bergridge account oh
okay just sitting there
yeah cool well here's what i would do if
i'm in your shoes i'm going to do a
direct rollover
from your old jobs traditional 401k and
i'm going to do a direct rollover to a
traditional ira
yeah that way you have no tax
implications right now and i would not
convert it over to roth which is going
to create a tax burden until you have a
paid for house because right now that is
your next goal is getting that house
paid off
yeah definitely i i i agree with that uh
that's where our budget's really tight
for getting the house paid off but
are you investing 15 percent
right now um and then i set it to
increase one percent per year until it
reaches 15. so you have no debt but the
mortgage but you don't have enough
margin to be investing 15 what's going
on there
uh well last year the previous employer
that i was at um
had a couple i got moved around and
ended up taking a couple pay cuts
after buying our house
okay and it ends up where just our our
budget is
right at our monthly expenses wow well
i'm going to try to get that income up
so we can get you investing 15
and i would start investing in the roth
401k option at your new job but leave
the old the old one roll it over direct
rollover traditional 401k to a
traditional ira and just leave it there
let's park it there and let's start
investing in the new job in the roth
401k option love that get that income
back up so that you're not drowning man
you got to get the margin in your life
especially with no debt payments you can
do this this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george camel flying solo today
give me a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'll talk about
your life
and your money
so i'm a millennial as many of you know
maybe you can tell by my voice i don't
know do i have a millennial voice james
is nodding yes i've got that npr
nasally tone there you go
so here's the deal as a millennial i
keep up with the trends i'm on social
media i'm on instagram reels checking
those out and of course you got to see
what's happening over on tick tock
and listen i'm a hard-working guy i'm
just out here trying to help people get
on a budget get out of debt
save for the future
and flying in the face of all of my hard
work
there's some people out there some gurus
that uh can't grow facial hair that are
out here telling you how to manage your
money
and better yet how to not manage your
money and one of those videos popped up
on my feed and uh it made my blood boil
and it's all about how stupid budgeting
is you guys want to watch it with me the
live audience is not a yes i'll take
that as a go let's watch this video
here are the three reasons why budgeting
sucks reason number one it almost always
puts you in a bad mindset right you have
this negative feeling towards money
reason number two is because it's like a
diet right we go on a diet we tell
ourselves ourselves we're not going to
eat certain things budgeting we tell
ourselves we're not going to buy certain
things or we restrict ourselves and
reason number three is because we all
have limited will power right just like
a diet you tell yourself you're not
going to eat that cookie eventually you
break down and you eat that cookie
budgeting we tell ourselves we're not
going to buy those shoes or whatever it
might be eventually we end up breaking
down and buying that thing and then we
just feel bad about ourselves
oh man
that actually he's hilarious he should
try stand-up comedy instead of being a
financial advisor
okay
so let's break this down
budgeting sucks because it puts you in a
bad mindset
okay alright so the alternative here
let's just play this logic out
if we're saying never do a budget
because it puts you in a bad mindset
instead
let's just spend
every dollar we make and more and never
worry about it what a great mindset to
have right until the payments show up
and you're wondering where your money
went
and you can't afford your four walls
how's that for a bad mindset
yeah
okay the next one
was budgeting is like a diet and diets
are bad
okay well let's look at how people lose
weight this is i'm not a scientist i'm
not claiming to be but it's all about
caloric deficit
so if you burn more calories than you
take in you will lose weight
if you live if you live on less than you
make
you can build wealth
and so budgeting is a necessary part of
that just like watching your food intake
so the last one uh was willpower he said
humans have terrible willpower so
budgeting sucks
okay he is right on that one we have
terrible willpower he said it sets you
up for failure too oh it sets you up for
failure thank you james it sets you up
for failure because we have limited
willpower as humans and therefore we
should just out earn our stupidity
keep spending and spending never make a
plan never pay attention never look at
the mirror bury our head in the sand oh
wait that's what america has done okay
i'm seeing what's happening now that is
why 78 of people live paycheck to
paycheck because they've all decided to
be like this guy and just go budgeting
sucks let's not do that
let me hit you with the reel on what a
budget does
a budget is telling your money where to
go instead of wondering where it went a
budget is permission to spend
that's all it is so a budget is actually
the most freedom you can have with money
because you know exactly what's
happening on paper every single month
and when you make a budget to go on a
thousand dollar vacation and you stick
to that budget
you come home with just good memories
sweet times maybe a tan if you're lucky
i can't get one
but when you do it without a budget you
come back with credit card debt
and you wonder how long you're gonna be
paying for this vacation that happened
three months ago and you're stressed out
because you know that bill's gonna come
due
and that's where most of america is at
they've got the credit card payments
they've got the car loans they have
student loan payments
and i get it budgeting is uh
it's tough to do it's tough to stick to
it has uh it requires discipline and so
yes if you think discipline is stupid
then uh i really question how you're
doing in every single other area of your
life
do you show up to work on time do you
work hard do you communicate with your
spouse
do you read books what other areas are
you just going well head in the sand who
cares willpower's hard diets are stupid
puts me in a bad mindset anytime you
make me work out or eat healthy goodness
gracious
but this is what people on the internet
are seeing and they're hitting the like
button and they're commenting and
they're saying oh my gosh yes dave
ramsey's the worst he doesn't want me to
have nice things no dave wants you to
have nice things he doesn't want nice
things to have you
that's the difference
he wants you to buy all the things that
you want to buy
but when you do it with other people's
money you put yourself in a really
really poor risky financial situation
so
that's my take on budgets and if you
listen to this guy you're going to agree
budgeters don't have fun you have to be
really good at math only people who
struggle need a budget only people who
are out of debt need a budget budgeting
takes too much time
budgets are too rigid too rigid guess
what you control the budget the budget
doesn't control you
all we're saying is list out your
expenses
list out your income let's make sure
that we have enough income to cover the
expenses it's that simple
okay my little baby rant is over i can't
handle it guys how many more of these
tick tocks are you gonna send us it's
too much i'm getting messages every
single day from viewers like you going
oh my gosh please respond to this and
there's only so much time in the day to
respond to stupidity that's the truth
and so you keep sending them because
it's entertaining for me
but i can't guarantee you it'll make the
show appreciate that all right let's go
to the phones where hopefully ben
doesn't frustrate me ben are you a good
guy he's in charlotte north carolina
welcome to the show man how you doing
pretty good how about you great what's
your question
hey so i'm getting married this june
awesome and
yeah thank you
and uh i don't have any student loans
but she does we are both still in
college and i was just wondering when is
it okay for me to start paying off this
little and would you advise me to do it
start before graduation or wait until
you both graduate okay great question
speak a little bit louder and clearer
into your phone for me as we continue
here
okay i'm sorry so you're getting married
in june she's got student loan debt you
don't you're both in college still
yes sir how much longer are we talking
are we graduating
soon
uh we both graduate with our undergrad
next spring
okay so we still have a year 2023 yes
sir so is she going to incur more debt
to finish school or is it over she
taking out all the loans she needs it
just depends on how much grant money and
other scholarship money we can get
okay
i asked that because right now your plan
is to invest in yourselves as you
graduate college so we don't need to be
focused on debt payoff quite yet what i
want you to do
is is stop the damage and stop the
bleeding and so i would stack up as much
cash as possible and make sure that we
can cash flow the rest of our college
experiences
okay and cash flow the wedding and get
our life together once we graduate it's
game on we are attacking this debt with
a vengeance but until we know 1 000
sure that we are gonna graduate without
taking on more debt i wouldn't start
paying it off quite yet
okay so how close is she do you think
she can cash flow this depending on the
grant money
um
i think
i think we should be able to cash flow
most of it
and i got a lot of scholarship money so
i'm going to try to see if i can also
help
transfer that money over to her
wow i've never heard of that
transferring a scholarship to another
person
i've heard of it working in some
instances i just got to make sure it'd
be okay in this specific scenario as
well
okay well good luck with that man but
either way i'm investing in y'all right
now we're going to pay off this debt as
soon as we graduate but we have to make
sure we don't go into more debt and if
you need to be scared silly go watch the
borrowed future documentary i'm also
going to give you an early wedding gift
hang on jenna's going to pick up i'm
going to gift you ramsay plus one year
subscription
it includes every dollar plus our
premium budgeting tool that connects to
your bank account it includes all of the
videos in financial peace university and
many many other resources tools courses
i want you both to sit through that as a
pre-marital counseling it's my gift to
you guys watch the videos together do
the budget together and as soon as
you're married combine accounts and
let's attack this debt with a vengeance
get it out of our lives forever and move
on with a beautiful long-lasting healthy
financially peaceful marriage that's
what i want for you ben hang on the line
jenna's gonna pick up and gift you that
ramsay plus subscription thanks so much
for the call this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome back to the ramsey show
i'm george campbell ramsey personality
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast
season one of the fine print is out
right now
where i help you uncover all the hidden
truths that are keeping you broke we did
11 episodes
and we covered the gamut we covered a
wide spectrum of financial issues from
student loans to bankruptcy to buy now
pay later to credit card rewards to
credit scores turns out there's no
shortage of financial traps out there
and there's a very small sliver of
things that you can do common sense
things to set yourself up for wealth you
can avoid all those distractions in the
traps and stay focused on the most
simplest way to build wealth you will be
unbelievably successful unbelievably
wealthy
get out of debt stay out of debt invest
consistently pay off your house it's
that simple it's the baby steps it's
worked for millions of people and it can
work for you
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five give me a
call and we will talk about your life
and your money that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five phone lines
are open and they are waiting for you
lisa joins us now in orlando florida
lisa welcome to the show
hey george how are you great how can i
help today
well i feel like i need a lot of help so
embarrassed to say i'm
i knew nothing that is so embarrassing
oh my gosh you're 47
47 and i feel like i'm 80. i'm very
stressed about money
it's okay it's not too late for you
i hope not i found you guys probably
about two years ago
um
raised four kids helping with the few
grandkids here and there and i got
custody of my mom and she's 85.
okay um
so with what i'm able to bring home
after insurance and everything it's
about
4 100 a month about 50 grand a year
so in my savings i have 40 000.
i i have left 46 to pay on my house
and
i have a 401k that has this well 20 000
but if i take it out to get i would get
around 15 000. don't take it out why are
you even contemplating that
well um
the house
is um almost paid so i thought maybe if
i took that out then i could maybe pay
it off within a year year and a half no
no you're robbing peter to pay paul over
here
okay don't take out the 401k loan you
can do this lisa
you got 46k left on the mortgage and you
have 40 000 saved you're doing great
what makes you think you're in such a
terrible financial position
um
well it's scary because i don't know
anything um
that's okay
finances whatsoever about ross four ones
i i don't know
how to put away for savings right now
because what i make is kind of
what's going out monthly based on the
mortgage insurances and how much is the
mortgage
uh the mortgage i paid 1200 a month it's
actually 836 dollars but i pay extra oh
well this is very reasonable
that's that's below 25 of your take-home
pay
yes sir okay so where are you saying you
don't have enough margin you're paying
all your bills are you investing
currently
no i'm not um
my mom's medications are kind of pricey
and like i said i help out the grandkids
i finally helped finance a car for my
son
which is only 9 000 left that's what do
you mean you helped him finance it you
co-signed
i co-signed
so you have you how much debt do you
have total outside of the mortgage
that's it nine thousand i paid off my
student loan the last payment i made
last month for three thousand dollars
okay
well that car loan scares me because
that's that's in your name that's your
debt
right
um
that payment's only 136 dollars a month
okay so how can i help today
well um
i've been listening and like with the
housing insurance market you know
they're threatening to take away our
housing insurance and the prices have
almost tripled and then i was listening
to the program where it said that if
something happened to your home they
wouldn't pay out what it cost to build
your home
um and i called the insurance company to
talk about that and they're telling me
that there's a clause that says that
they have to replace it at cost
and so who's threatening to take your
insurance away
uh
there are insurance companies here in
florida that have gone under and out of
business
so we're only left with a couple choices
when's the last time you shopped around
for home insurance
uh i i'm currently in the process of
shopping okay i would shop with someone
who's not captive and so our friends are
xander insurance this is what they do
all day long that's who i have my own
personal home insurance through and
they're going to shop all of the
companies across the nation and they're
only going to choose the best companies
okay so i would jump onto
ramseysolutions.com
and click on trusted pros and get
connected with xander to help you shop
for home insurance and they're going to
find highly rated companies that aren't
about to go under that aren't about to
rip the rug out from under you
but outside of that what else is going
on that's freaking you out
it's getting older and not having
anything paid for retirement
well we can work on that for sure you
have twenty thousand dollars in
retirement that's it right
that's it what do you do for work
uh i'm a nurse awesome so you've got
some some good investing options at work
we're just a 401
okay that's all you need in our in our
research of millionaires we studied over
10 000 that was the most likely path to
be a millionaire their company 401k
so i want to encourage you you don't
have to get fancy you don't have to keep
up with the latest trends in
cryptocurrency and nfts to build wealth
and you've got what another let's say 20
years of your working life ahead of you
before you retire
uh hopefully yeah okay so over the
course of 20 years if you invest
15 of your income and once you have that
house paid off we can invest even more
and once we have this car loan out of
our life we can invest even more
then with all the ketchup contributions
you can make past 50 you're gonna be
okay
if you invest consistently into that
401k into some good growth stock mutual
funds you don't have to know all the ins
and outs to build wealth that is the
beautiful part of our plan
you just have to consistently do the
actions
we can teach you along the way so what
i'm going to do
have you been through financial peace
before financial peace university
i have not okay this
changed the game for me
it's going to teach you the books and
read them a library
that's great you can get total money
makeover from the library there i'm
happy to send you a copy as well and
i'll also gift you one year of ramsay
plus
and what i want you to do is oh
absolutely i think once you read total
money makeover and you watch all nine
lessons of financial peace university
dave and our team we're gonna walk you
through exactly what you need to know
and really all you need to know in order
to build wealth
and again you don't have to be a
financial expert you just have to be
willing to do the actions and we have
teams in place you know we have uh
smartvestor pros those are investing
professionals in your area in orlando
that can help you do things the ramsey
way
you can get in touch with one of
ramseysolutions.com
and they'll help you understand what
you're investing in they don't just tell
you what to invest in they want you to
understand it and you can make an
educated decision so i want to encourage
you lisa number one it's not too late
you're 47 you're not 87.
you're only halfway there
and so let's just start making some good
decisions you already have you've got a
ton of money saved up let's call that
the emergency fund you could knock out
this car loan today if you wanted to you
could fully fund an ira if you wanted to
you've got lots of options here
and your income is going to continue to
go up isn't it
i don't think so i'm kind of maxed out
in this position i took this position
because i can work in the evenings and i
can still take care of my mom because
those kids are very expensive yeah
well i'm sorry that you're
you've got that burden on you i know you
love your mom i can tell but it's a lot
for you right now i feel that in your
voice and what you've described taking
on not only the physical burden of
taking care of her but the financial
burden too of covering medications and
grandkids and all kinds of things
yeah believe it or not she's number 11
that i'm taking care of in my family wow
lisa you feel like i'm you're a warrior
i know i know but we're going to get you
there hang on the line jenna's going to
pick up we're going to gift you ramsay
plus one year of that plug into it we're
going to send you a copy of the total
money makeover and get you going in good
shape here in no time thank you so much
for the call lisa that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it
[Applause]
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
george campbell ramsey personality
joined today by
me myself and i just riding solo guys
and we're having a good time so far and
we are so glad you've decided to join us
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
to call
maybe you're worried about inflation
maybe you're about to make a big
financial decision you need some
confirmation some encouragement i'm here
for you
gerard is kicking off this hour he's in
philadelphia pennsylvania gerard welcome
to the
hey
show
how are you great how can i help today
so
i graduated law school about five years
ago with 145 000 in student loans
i
got a car and a condo which i know
wasn't the best idea but um
i ended up last year selling the condo
for a 50 000 profit and i paid down a
lot of that
debt um
so up until about a month ago my debt
was student loan debt was still 106 000
i uh
i got a bonus at my job
of about
91 000 which was
more than my salary and uh
yeah
last week
i decided that
i was waiting around to see what would
happen with the pause and i i wrote a
check for
106 000
and paid off all my loans whoa that's
awesome good for you man and
yeah yeah thank you and you don't sound
excited
let's oh yeah i i
paid down pretty much
all of my debt but it drained almost all
of my money and uh i just found out
today that they're extending that pause
again and
my friends are giving me a hard time and
i'm just kind of like your friends are
broke aren't they worried about
they are they are broke lawyers as well
yeah so let's not take opinions from
broke lawyers let's take opinions from
lawyers who have no payments in the
world
yeah and so i mean i i don't have that
much money left but i was just sort of
wondering where to go from here
yeah what's your household income
uh it's just me it's uh 80 80 000 as my
base salary okay so let's say 80 000
base and you have no more debt you still
have the car loan
no no that was the last of it so you
have zero debt
zero debt um and i
i i moved back home my parents are in
florida and i decided to stay at their
house while they're there and i did that
was a huge help and paying down my debt
but i kind of want to get on my own but
i now i don't have that much money and
i'm kind of so how much money do you
have to your name in savings and [ __ ]
your checking account
uh savings and checking combined about
13 000.
and to you that's zero dollars you said
you have no money
uh no it's money but i mean
you know it well to go from
you know 125 to the bank and 13 in a
week is kind of
yeah but we've got to look at you're 125
in the bank with 106 in debt you don't
have 125 000 to your name
that's true so when you look at your net
worth right what you own minus what you
owe
it's a very different picture
if i've got 200 000 in the bank but i
owe 2 million
i'm
broke right and so i want you to be
encouraged that you did the right thing
it sounds like you've got some remorse
here some regret
yeah i just think because they they just
announced today that they're causing
those payments i don't care if they kick
it to 2028 man you did the right thing
by paying off your debt
there's no point kicking the can down
the road even further because how much
was your student loan payments
when you add them up um
when they when they restarted they
probably would have been
uh probably eight or nine hundred a
month okay so let's do some basic math
here 900 a month
times 12
means you can invest that money you can
save that money that's money back in
your pocket
from your hard work
not going to a lender
to make them rich so they can build
another building downtown
so i don't want you to have any any fomo
about how you pay it off your student
loan debt and your friends are going
dude you're an idiot they're gonna
they're gonna keep pausing it until
three years from now and they're gonna
continue to be broke
they're gonna continue to live on
payments i want to encourage you you're
going down the right path you make 80
grand you have 13 in the bank what is
three to six months of expenses for you
uh about eight
eight was about um about three months
that's five months okay so let's call it
10. let's call 13. you've got your
emergency fund in place
now let's begin investing 15 percent
okay do you have any retirement options
i did put
i have a roth ira
that my family told me to start before i
started making too much money
and that has 23 in it and then i have
um a 401k that was just started and has
four in it great
so let's invest
and this is the way i would do it match
beats roth beats traditional so do they
have a match in the 401k
uh no it's just a it's a flat
contribution regardless of what i
contribute okay so that's already busted
and then i'm going to move to the roth
options so do we have a roth 401k or is
it just traditional um
it's not it's just a traditional 401k
and then i have my own roth ira those
are my only two so if i'm in your shoes
i'm going to fully fund the roth ira for
the year with my paychecks once i'm done
with that i'm fully funded i'm going to
put the remaining 15 into my work
traditional 401k until i hit 15 percent
okay that's it
and if you do that and you're renting
right now well i'm my parents are in
florida and i'm staying with that i'm
staying here
in florida okay um
but i i would like to get my own place
because i'm coming back soon
so beyond that we can start saving up
for a house down payment and i want you
to save 10 to 20
15 year fixed rate mortgage where the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay if you do those
things you are going to have what we
call financial peace and you're going to
do it really quickly because you're not
paying a lender 900 a month that same
900 now becomes your down payment
savings you see where i'm going with
this
right
yeah i do
man i'm more excited than you are i'm
ready to get into this house man i'm
ready to do some things you got to stop
listening to your friends
yeah he was just you know it was just it
was the biggest check i ever wrote by
about a factor of 10.
so it's kind of
you know a lot of fomo like you said
well you didn't really have that money
because you owed it and debt is when you
owe anything to anyone for any reason
and so you had a facade that you had a
lot of money and i'm proud of you for
even saving up that much money that's
unfathomable to a lot of people
but i want you to be encouraged that
that money had a name it had the
lender's name on it from day one when
you signed those papers to take out 146
000 in student loan debt
you owed that money
right
well gerard i've gone as far as i can go
man
i don't know why you're bummed out i
mean america's cheering you on going
gerard way to go the whole crowd out
here and ramsay solutions lobby is
cheering you on you did the right thing
you just got to stop hanging out with
broke lawyers
your life will change drastically man
get plugged in with people following the
ramsey plan you're gonna realize
man i'm on the right path i'm doing the
right things for my financial future i'm
not doing things to impress anybody
anymore i'm doing what's right for
gerard and that is how you know you are
winning thanks for the call man this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
george campbell your host today flying
solo give me a call triple eight eight
two five five two two five
all right so i recently spoke with
our lawyer friend the line gerard
and he had some regret about stroking
the check to pay off the rest of his 106
000 student loan balance because his
lawyer friends were clowning him saying
dude they're gonna keep pausing student
loan forgiveness what are you they're
going to keep pausing the student loan
payments what are you doing man just
leave it alone what's the point in
paying it off
and so we just got when that the biden
administration is kicking the can down
the road again that's what they're
alluding to
now through the end of august they are
pausing student loan payments
and let me tell you
uh
the people that come here and do their
debt-free screen
so many of them have said man that
student loan pause helped me pay off my
debt faster because we attacked it with
a vengeance while it was paused while we
didn't have to make payments while
interest wasn't accruing that helped us
get ahead and make extra payments on
principle and knock this thing out
and you'll hear people in the borrowed
future documentary go i took out 120 000
but it turned into 200.
how did that happen
and it's all because of interest that's
how this works the average student loan
balance
when you graduate right now is
seven hundred 38
ninety two dollars keeps going up
average loan term about ten years
average interest rate about five point
eight percent
and so me and james the producer and ben
and zach were in there just being nerds
just crunching some numbers for you
america
and i want to report back some
interesting findings
when student loans got paused back in
2020
let's just say
that you didn't make any payments
well the interest isn't accruing so you
feel pretty good about yourself there's
no payments
but let's say you did
pay on those loans and you got them
knocked out
here's some of the savings you would
have had
year one
you would have been paying 1645 in
interest
year two you would have paid 20 41 in
interest and year three 1858 in interest
so that comes out to about fifty five
hundred dollars you save
by just paying off those student loans
and not dealing with that interest while
it's not there
so i want to encourage you america to
pay off your student loans regardless of
when
the payments are going to get unpaused
because now is the time this is a gift
from the government which never happens
except for those stimulus checks that
was fun while it lasted
but this is a gift because they're not
having your payments accrue interest you
can attack the principal you can make
progress faster than ever using the debt
snowball
list out all of your debts from smallest
to largest regardless of the interest
rate which is hilarious because we're
not dealing with interest rate right now
with these student loans and then knock
them out from smallest to largest and
you're going to make so much progress
and you're going to be on this stage
right across here from the glass from me
doing your debt-free scream
that's what i want for you i want those
payments to turn into savings to turn
into investments the opportunity cost of
you not using that 900 towards your
goals towards your investments and
instead giving it to sally may
you think you're doing anyone a favor
but them
man
so i don't care when they kick the can
down the road i don't care if it's 20 28
20 38
you got to get this debt out of your
life they're not doing you any favors
that's my rant for the day the second
one james you're welcome take count
there aaron is joining us up next in
fort myers florida aaron welcome to the
ramsay show
hey george thanks thanks for having me
on the show absolutely how can i help
today
so
um
for my wife and i we um have taken uh
serious the baby steps and trying to pay
off our credit card debt currently
that's what we're trying to do for about
the last six months
we've been trying to do that we started
uh
2022 uh just from years of bad habits
and not making a lot of money with about
35 000 credit card debt
we
for a couple of those credit cards they
went into collections just because we
were unable to make those payments
um so for the
start of 2022 until now we've been able
to knock out about ten thousand dollars
of those credit cards so that was two of
those credit cards awesome we currently
have three we currently have three more
two of those are in collections so
that's about a total of about fifteen
thousand dollars that are in collections
um and then we have another credit card
that is not in collections and that's
about ten thousand dollars so we have
about 25
000 left
uh to pay in credit cards now i have
already spoken to one of them it's been
collections they've given me an offer
and with that offer we feel like that's
something we want to do it's like 60 of
the 8 000 amount
we want to pay that off in three
payments but we're while we're doing
that we're unable to make the minimum
payments on the one that's not in
collections
so my question is
do we allow that just to go
does lapse and just go into collections
while we're trying to knock off these
well now smaller amounts
because of the offer that they've given
us to knock out those credit cards just
kind of to have that snowball effect to
get rid of a credit card focus on the
next one
until we can have you communicated with
that third card and said hey listen
we're trying our best to get out of this
thing we're not gonna be able to make
payments for the next three months
so
we actually my wife just got off the
phone today with that credit card that
is not in collection
they basically told us there's nothing
they could do they have no offers for us
to lower the interest or to make the
payments lower they said the only thing
we could do
is for you to make that minimum payment
in april and maybe after that we can
talk that was the only thing that we
tried after talking to a couple
different people
and so that's where we're at
are you guys working 70 hours a week yet
probably well definitely more i am a
first responder here in fort myers and
uh
i probably average between 90 to 120
hours a week whoa
dude that is next level so what's your
household income right now
so this past year because i actually
just transitioned i was in ministry and
so i wasn't i was making okay for what i
did but i wasn't making a lot transition
to first responder um base income is
about 50 and i ended i just finished a
year
doing that i ended at 65 just with all
the overtime 65 000 and um
my wife is a stay-at-home mom three kids
and uh so yeah 65 000 is what we made in
20
well this calendar year i should say
okay
is she able to do any kind of work
outside the home even part time remote
it would be difficult we could do it
just um our kids are in a private school
which is something we're actually
switching over we're going to homeschool
next year
which will save us some money there
you're too broke to be in private school
at this point exactly yeah what other
debt do you have
we have um we have school loans and
that's it our school loans is something
we currently just realize we're going to
have to put on the back burner
we want to get rid of our credit cards
and then move on to school loans we have
about 30 in school loans as well and no
car payments
no we own thankfully we own our two vans
okay
well i want you to be in direct
communication with all of the the
collectors the credit card companies be
proactive about this
and make sure that you get the agreed
amounts in writing whether that is
physically they mail it to you or they
email it something that you can print
out keep copies of that
because you need proof that this is what
they said they said
and then don't give them any access to
your checking account don't give them
any personal information about your
income where you work none of that
and then once you agree on the terms
we're going to be about the business of
knocking this out
and i would try if they've agreed to
settle on that 60 talk to them and say
hey listen i can do this i've got to
keep up with this card over here but i
can start this payment plan in a month
are you okay with that
and my guess is they're gonna say cool i
mean if you're gonna send us money we'll
we'll take it when we can get it at this
point
yes but i would not send this other card
to collections and have to deal with
this one over here you're trying to
juggle too many balls and they're going
to drop
and so what you can do is be in direct
communication let them know here's what
i can do listen i'm we're trying our
best here i'm working 120 hours a week
as a first responder in fact don't tell
me your first responder but just tell me
you're working your tail off
to get rid of this debt and you want to
do it you know you owe some money
and see what they're willing to settle
for across the board if you can save up
that amount in cash and do lump sums you
can do payment plans do that but make
sure that you are in control of the
conversation don't let them dictate your
life
okay so you would recommend trying to
talk to collections see what we can do
to navigate that and don't let that
other card go into collection i would
not just let it fall into collections
because you can't make it that's a worse
worst case scenario man wishing the best
for you guys as you climb out of this
pile of debt and when you do please
never look back never go into debt again
man your family's on the line here you
love them do what's right for them get
out of debt stay out of debt build for
the future leave a legacy that's what
this plan is all about this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
you are listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcasts open phones this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five
i wanna talk to teachers out there for a
second
all year long you teachers have been
grinding it out to make sure your
students are actually learning despite
all of the distractions they're dealing
with right now and you guys work so hard
and you care even harder it's teachers
like you who've taught our foundations
and personal finance curriculum and
changed the lives of over 5 million
students across the country that's
incredible
our curriculum is now in 48 of schools
across america and if you've ever
wondered man why don't they teach us the
stuff in school well we're out there
we're doing this thing
and teachers are leading the charge and
we want to celebrate teachers this month
because it is national financial
literacy month and the teachers out
there are helping our students get
financially well and learn all of these
things we want to celebrate teachers
with our special teacher appreciation
giveaway sponsored by borrowed future
our hit documentary about the dark side
of the student loan industry so this
month teachers can enter the giveaway to
win some awesome cash prizes two lucky
teachers will win five thousand dollars
cash each to use however they want and
three teachers will win an additional
one thousand dollars cash and there's
more prizes where that came from so
don't miss out teachers if you know one
you've got one in your life please tell
them about this go to
ramseysolutions.com teacher for a chance
to win all right let's go to the phones
chris joins us in cleveland what's up
chris
hey george thanks for taking my call
absolutely what's going on with you
so um
we
we have we have some rental properties
seven of them
and they're the only things that we have
debt on at this point five of them in
fact still have mortgages on them
and i have a tenant moving out at the
beginning of may
and my my thought is perhaps i should
sell that property
because it would enable me to pay off
of at least uh four of the properties
that do have mortgages on them where i
only have one mortgage left i love that
plan
i could have about a ten thousand dollar
capital gains tax that i have to pay as
a result however
um you know i would still i would then
be realizing a higher capital gains on
the remaining properties yeah i mean i
like this plan what's stopping you from
doing it
just making sure i'm not missing
anything to be honest no i mean you know
our stance we want you to uh have paid
for real estate and so if you were going
back in time and say hey let's do it
slow let's pay cash for these but the
fact that you're wanting to get out of
this debt as soon as possible i think
it's great if you can sell one i mean do
you love it are you going to miss it
um i mean it's a it produces nice i mean
it's we own it free and clear
we don't we only owe about of the total
value of the properties about 25 percent
of the total value of the properties of
the debt okay
so that's the other thing i'm like okay
if i just and i never i didn't take any
more than a 15-year mortgage on any of
them wow so
um that's kind of one struggle i think
should i just so you sell one you pay
off four and you just have one mortgage
left in your life
correct man and well that's going to
free up a lot of payments isn't it that
you are making on the mortgage
certainly how is that for cash flow
well yeah
even without the seventh property i end
up with about a thousand dollar more
cash flow on a monthly basis to where i
could clear that at the last mortgage
and hopefully pay that off within you
know a couple years yeah that'll speed
up your progress on that last one and
you have a paid for primary residence
yes
awesome and no other debt to speak of no
no how old are you
um i'm 50. wow well you've done really
well man you've made some great um you
know investing decisions aside from
taking on the debt i mean you you were
really diligent about the whole process
not getting yourself underwater here so
do you want to be in real estate long
term
yes i mean i might i'd like to have 10
to 15 properties ultimately is my kind
of my retirement plan if you will beyond
my 401k my step and my wife's retirement
stuff that's fantastic so you guys are
investing for the future you've got that
you've got cash flow from rentals and
you're going to retire with multi
millions of dollars
yes that's the plan i like this plan a
lot well i'm selling this thing today
knocking out the other four mortgages i
got one left and then you can build some
serious wealth when you have all that
cash flow all your income and you're not
making a payment to anyone
yeah that's kind of what i was thinking
but i just was thinking maybe i should
just
let it ride for the last few years here
and then you know go at it slowly but at
the same time i really like the idea of
not having those anymore yeah
four birds one stone and you can always
get some more real estate later on
right that's my thought way to go man
thank you so much for the call
thanks for confirming my thoughts i
really appreciate it i was worried about
it absolutely that's what i'm here for a
little smile in your day a little pep in
your step little encouragement
valdo joins us next in omaha nebraska
valdo welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me did i say that
right is it valdo or valdo
volvo you said it right nailed it rhymes
with waldo perfect okay what's going on
how can i help
um so my question today is should i cash
out part of my retirement accounts to
pay off the personal loan
that i took out to pay off my soon to be
ex-wife from the pending divorce
this just got real complicated how old
are you
yeah
i just turned 28. no we are not going to
touch retirement
okay the penalties on that i mean it'd
be like taking out a loan at 35 percent
interest
yeah
it's a bad move so let's say cashing out
retirement is not on the table what do
what do we owe what's the debt owed here
i owe
10 grand on student loans 11 grand on
the car and
22 grand on that personal line and
that's all i have
okay and so what's going on with the x
um we
split up about three months ago and
we're going to divorce here in about 30
days waiting on the courts um but i'm
gonna
tell her about 18k and that's why i took
out the first amount to cover the
divorce costs so you have the money to
pay her the 18k
yeah okay but you have 22 that you took
out
yeah instead of 18.
yeah and
on top of this uh
in the past three months i've paid off
about 20 grand and other debt why'd it
go
okay so we're all set here with paying
her so we don't need to go into any more
debt right
you're just looking for you're looking
for a shortcut to get rid of the debt
you currently have
yeah and so you're going to rob your
retirement with a 401k loan or
cash it out
to do this i don't like that plan how
quickly could we clean up this debt just
using the debt snowball listing about
smallest largest paying them off
regardless of interest rate
by christmas
i like that plan what a great christmas
gift to yourself especially after what
you've gone through this year
yeah yeah definitely and so there's not
a good shortcut to get out of debt other
than paying off the debt methodically
and so that's where the debt snowball
comes in and now how much is the car
worth
it's
about 18 grand
so you got 11 grand
on the loan it's worth 18. if you sold
it you'd have 7k
yeah
could you buy a car for 7 000 that would
get you from a to b
right now
yeah it could
that feels like it would speed up your
progress leaving you with 32 000 left
your student loan on the personal loan
and then after christmas valdo gets to
give himself a great gift and you can
upgrade the car because you're out of
debt we're going to get a fully funded
emergency in place and we'll get you
back in a better car would you be
willing to do that to speed up the
process by months
yeah i think i would
i like that plan
because i mean out of your debt the car
loan is it's a big chunk
yeah it's a fourth of your debt just
sitting there if i can knock out a
fourth of my debt today
i'm doing it
yeah and that car originally uh leased
it i bought it i was financing but
that's always hanging over my head too
yeah man i just want you to simplify
your life you've gone through a lot um i
know how hard divorce is and i'm so
sorry you're going through that and so
what i want for you is just
a deep breath some simplicity no
payments
just valdo starting his new life with no
debt and if you can do that by christmas
by selling this car or even faster
that's what i'm doing
so i'm pulling for you man i'm so so
sorry you're going through this but the
faster we can clean up this debt without
the shortcuts the better and selling
that car is one of the only shortcuts
i'm okay with
because it's not robbing your retirement
that you've worked really hard for
thanks so much for the call this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcast you can check all of those out
at ramseysolutions.com on the ramsey
network or wherever you listen to
podcasts open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number to call marcia joins us
next all the way from cincinnati ohio
marsha welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
absolutely how can i help
so
i have um
have many questions but um i have one
question i wanted to know how to
um i guess verify
letters
um that you're not sure if it would be a
scam or not because i got a letter i
used to i was in the military for uh 10
years and i got in military i got a
letter from
um
efas so the department of finance uh
saying that i owed a social security tax
and i just wasn't 100 sure if this was
like a scam or if this was real um i
know people can really make documents
like you know detailed to make it look
real so i just wanted to call and get
your advice on how to know if something
is a scam or not yeah well generally if
you think it's a scam it's a scam
it's a scam okay so i mean i'm not
saying ignore it i would try to verify i
would actually call go to their website
of whoever you think it's actually from
so if it's the irs or you know
department of finance call them directly
at their number because what they can do
is they can actually spoof those numbers
and so if the call is incoming to you it
may look like a real call from the irs
right even if it's not and so there's
lots of scams happening out there
especially around tax time this is when
scammers make their money and so i would
just verify with them have you called
them directly
not yet i just got the letter today and
i'm it just
you know threw me off guard of like what
it what is this you know so i just
wanted to call and see i know you guys
have talked about scams you know a lot
so that's why i would wanted to call and
get your advice on you know what to go
about how to go about verifying if this
was you know a real document or this was
you know a scam so yeah well if it has
the address on there the number i mean
you can i would start googling doing
some research figure out who's actually
contacting me and is this legit does it
have sensitive information that you're
like how do they get this does it have
your social security number on there
uh let me i would have to look and see
um let me see
does it have payment options what is it
actually saying yes it's it's from right
the defense finance and accounting
service and it has my home of record
and then from what i see
it gives you like a qr scan code option
to pay
um and then
i wouldn't scan that if i were to
letters no they're probably hoping you
they're probably hoping you scan that
and it probably could it could be some
virus it could ask for sensitive
information
and so i would not scan that i would
ignore it but what i would do is i'm
looking at their website right now i'm
going to go to their contact info
and get in touch with them and say hey i
got this letter in the mail here's what
it says and i'm 99 sure they're going to
say oh that's a scam just rip it up and
throw it out don't worry about it okay
because like it's like i i mean and the
dates are from when i was in the
military back in 2020 and i was active
duty and they're saying and i separated
over uh this past summer and i'm like
why is this now just coming to me you
know that makes that makes me kind of
iffy on like why wasn't this taken care
of when i was active duty and that's why
i'm calling i'm just doesn't settle
right with me so oh absolutely all right
well go on their website get in touch
with them but my my guess is you're
ripping up that letter and uh avoiding
it so i'm proud of you for being
vigilant and seeing the red flag and
going
i'm not going to pay this and i want to
encourage all of america to do the same
thing if it if you get a weird gut
feeling
uh you're probably right and so i always
like to do my research contact people
through their legitimate websites call
them don't let them call you
and letters are next level i mean that
you can forge that make it look like
it's really coming from that place and
so do your due diligence for sure all
right moving on we're headed nearby to
dayton ohio cory joins us there corey
welcome to the show
corey are you with us
there's corey did i do that right
uh i'm from ann arbor but but i am corey
oh there's multiple cory's okay hang on
corey we're coming back to you we're
coming back no
worries all right there did i do that
right hold on
guys i'm really struggling today corey
are you with us
yeah i'm here can you hear me wow i hit
a whole bunch of buttons there i'm glad
glad you made it
oh thank you what's going on well i have
a question about what my next step
should be i'm in baby step four five and
six
and i'm just about to complete my
associate's degree
um i've just got a job as an intern for
a job that will help me get a my my
full-time employment and what i'm going
to school for awesome i'm wondering what
i should be focusing on next with my
money should i be going for paying off
my bachelor's degree or
focusing on retirement or maybe even
using a va loan to get a home loan okay
hold on you just told me that you are in
baby step 456 but you're talking about
paying off your bachelor's degree
yeah because i'm about to graduate with
the associate's degree i'm debt-free
right now okay to get the bachelor's
degree i'll have to go into debt well
we'll have to those are some fighting
words corey
why do you have to
uh
i guess i don't have to it's just the
there we go fastest way to get it
the fastest way but is it the best way
probably not no so let's focus on the
best way so that you don't start your
adult life
paying your student loan debt and
wondering why you don't make enough
money
well i'm 30 uh so i've been in there for
a little bit okay
so how much money do you have to your
name
i have about uh twelve thousand dollars
okay so you got twelve thousand dollars
you're debt free let's call that your
emergency fund is that enough for three
to six months of expenses
i have a emergency fund of five thousand
dollars set aside okay outside of the
12.
no it's part of the 12. okay well let's
separate those two so don't get confused
because all of a sudden you're not sure
what's what when it comes to emergencies
so i'm going to try to cash flow this
experience have you done your research
to see if this is the most affordable
option to to do what you want to do
yes i have at the end of it it'll be
about 27 000
uh
of the student loan if i chose to do
that
and um
which i really like to avoid yeah i mean
so my question is how quickly could we
save up that much money how quickly
could we apply for scholarships like a
part-time job in order to bring that
cost down in order to do that thing
without debt do you need the bachelor's
degree right now or can you get to work
uh not really with uh for computer
science and the bachelor's degree is
what sets aside for a software developer
job hold on man you're telling me you
need a bachelor's degree to do computer
science
for to be a software developer yeah
incorrect
i don't buy that there's so many courses
online you can do they're looking for a
skill set they don't care about the
piece of paper
really i'm telling you right now we have
so we have hundreds of developers here
at ramsey solutions and if you quiz them
and ask them about their their college
experience i guarantee you there'd be a
large majority that didn't have the
traditional bachelor's degree route
and so i would be taking pause
you got your associates done let's take
a pause let's actually look at the jobs
you'd want to do
contact those employers and say hey
listen here's my situation do i need the
bachelor's degree or is there other
certifications that i can do and i think
you're going to finally go yeah we just
want someone who can code
okay yeah so i don't think you need to
go another 27 thousand dollars in debt
to do this
okay well that's good news so i would do
a lot of research um you mentioned a lot
of things you could be doing with your
money right now i want to focus on
getting that job that you want and not
going into debt to do it
once you're there boom then we can focus
on starting to invest 15 percent because
we don't have debt we have a fully
funded emergency fund we can start
talking about a house and all the
different goals that you have but i want
you to focus on getting this education
to the path that you want to take
so should i maybe do this at the
internship i have currently or should i
drop this internship and is it a paid
internship yes it's paid but it's not
paid very much so what's the goal of the
internship to gain experience
uh to gain experience so i could become
a software developer when i got my
bachelor's degree is what i was
originally thinking but that's kind of
changed now well if you're gaining
experience through the internship do you
need the bachelor's
uh
i i don't know i i i really don't i
think we've got some questions to answer
corey but i hope i steered you away from
just willy-nilly just wandering into
some more student loan debt to hope that
you get this job so i'm pulling for you
but i'm telling you in that world you
don't need a piece of paper that says
corey is good at coding you just need to
be good at coding
rooting for you man that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books my
thanks to uh no co-host today so i guess
thanks to myself thanks to all the folks
in the booth making the show happen and
thank you america for tuning in we can't
do the show without you we love you
we'll be back with you before you know
it
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
ramsey personality george campbell and i
am honored to take your calls and help
you out today with whatever questions
you have
for those of you that don't know me uh
i've been around here a long time
celebrating nine years at ramsey
solutions this year started as an intern
worked in marketing for several years
worked uh as one of our hosts for live
events in the video channel if you're
around for those days and more recently
ramsey personality helping people
with their money questions their money
problems trying to educate people out
there help young people avoid debt
trying to help old people avoid debt
everyone's involved here
and i followed the baby steps to a t
and ended up in baby step 7 with a paid
4 house
last year and man what a journey it has
been these steps changed my life and if
i can help these steps change your life
today i will have done a good service
so open phones this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number to call we'll talk about your
life and your money daniella has decided
to do that she joins us in dallas texas
to kick off the hour what's up daniella
hello george hey how can i help today
um we have a family question
so i've got a family answer all right
that's awesome so my mom unfortunately
is in poor health right now
we are actually in the process of
finalizing her will to just make sure
that everybody's going to be okay
when she's gone
and um what we're figuring out is that
the estate will be split 50 50 between
my sister and myself with me being the
executor
but there's one piece of the puzzle that
i'm trying to kind of simplify and i
want to get your thoughts sure so
my car or my sister's car that she
drives is owned by my mom and my sister
is in her um early 20s this was the car
that she
got from my mom you know when she was
still living in her household when she
was a teenager so this is kind of like a
leftover transaction that was never
fully signed over to my sister now that
she's a young adult
um i'm thinking that to avoid probate
with me being the executor and just kind
of simplifying these transactions
if it's her wish that the car go to my
sister anyways couldn't we just sign
over the title to my sister
um now
clean up that transaction and then truly
the will be will be
50 50 at that point upon execution
when that day comes
am i am i overlooking something like
gift tax or
other tax paperwork that we should
consider
yeah well you're very wise to even be
thinking through all that and i'm so so
sorry to hear about your mom
thank you
so
in texas that's where you are right the
car is there or you're all there
so this is in texas this very state to
state when it comes to gift tax usually
it just falls under the gift tax laws up
to fifteen thousand so if the car is
valued at fifteen thousand um then you
would be exempt
but in texas it's interesting uh based
on my research you will owe ten dollars
in gift tax so you can sign over the
title
you can do a bill of sale for you know
zero dollars to gift this make sure that
she signs the title properly you guys
fill all that out carefully but it
sounds like you're on the hook for ten
bucks outside of your counties you know
registration fees title fees all that
stuff
okay so i would not know that i would
run it by uh you know a tax pro and a
state attorney if you want to but based
on my research which you know i like to
research
that is what that's what i'm finding for
the state of texas
so you shouldn't have a problem doing
that right now and not have that be part
of the will and just put the car in her
name but i would do it by the book so do
some research for your your county or
area you can even call your county
clerk's office and say hey listen here's
what we're trying to do we just want to
make sure that we follow the right steps
what are the costs involved what do we
need to do what do we need to bring and
i'll tell you this from personal
experience because i was at the county
clerk's office yesterday
and they were like oh your wife didn't
sign the title and oh we need your
marriage certificate so i'd call ahead
of time so you don't have to go back
uh and wait in line there again
fantastic ideas george with a k oh thank
you so much i appreciate the call so
sorry to hear about your mom but i'm so
proud of you for taking the right steps
for making sure that we have the will in
place for communicating about this
that's such a huge step that so many
people don't take and it causes you know
relational damage financial damage and
so i'm proud of you guys for handling
this with maturity and care thanks so
much for the call all right corey joins
us in ann arbor michigan cory you're
back
i'm back okay sorry about the mishap
earlier but you're here now how can i
help
no worries man i really appreciate
taking the call
what's going on so
so uh
i'm i'm a little bit late to the party
on the baby steps right so it's all
right i'm a new uh new listener um as of
you know a couple months we love new
recruits i feel like
yeah yeah good so i'm uh i feel like i'm
in a decent financial situation my baby
steps are a little jumbled up right now
but i'm nearly clear of that so so
here's my question
my dream i've got a dream of owning some
waterfront property
live in michigan
and whether that be my my primary
residence or uh buying a place uh up
north to kind of have a family getaway
and that's just always been my dream um
something i'm looking to accomplish so
i'm wondering
what
what steps do i need to take to get
there because i have two small kids that
i want to be able to enjoy this before
they're
too old to give a crap about what dad's
up to and and going up north with them
um how old are you
i'm 32. okay and you have a mortgage
right now you're in a a home
yeah i have a mortgage right now um
it's uh we owe about 238 000 on it and
it's worth about 350k okay what's your
household income
uh we're at about 225.
awesome great income and so
do you guys want to live there now like
would you sell your home and go live in
that waterfront property if you could
get it
so if i i would do that if i could do it
around here because i don't want to
change my my kid's school system they're
in a great school system they're they're
settled um and we really like where
we're at um
i i would prefer to either have a place
up there that we can go during the
summer his wife and i both are work
remote
but i don't think i would i wouldn't
live there unless i could do it right
around here and
with the where the way property values
are around here for me to get on the
lake that i'd like to be on
yeah yeah okay so do you have any
directly outside of the mortgage
so outside of the mortgage i i uh
unfortunately i'm in a fleece right now
but my plan is to to buy that cash as
soon as as soon as it's up which is in a
year do you have an emergency fund you
have any savings
yeah so i've got uh i've got 40k in
emergency fund um i've got uh 107k
in my roth 401k and my wife's 401k is at
about 12k
and then i've got about 8k saved up for
my kids college already okay well here's
what i'll tell you you can
rent somewhere in the summers if you
want to spend a week at some waterfront
property but for now we've got to clean
up the debt let's get the fully funded
emergency fund in place invest 15
pay off our house and we can get we can
get there to that new property and if
you want to sell this one eventually and
get in that new one but do it on a
15-year fixed rate with a payment of no
more than a quarter of your take-home
pay and make sure that you're putting a
healthy down payment down i want 20 or
more and you can do that you have a
fantastic income you're gonna get there
in no time but follow the baby steps in
order they work when you do them in
order cory thanks so much for the call
call me back from that waterfront
property man good for you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell your host today open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five well all of our
team here ramsey solutions are a buzz
about dr john delony's new book own your
past change your future it's on a
pre-sale right now for just 20 bucks
crazy how time flies and the pre-order
is almost over feels like just yesterday
john has taken his two phds his 20 years
of counseling experience and he's packed
it into an easy to understand book even
i can understand folks and this book is
not just for people who are healing from
terrible trauma from their past this is
a book for everyone it applies to
everyone in every walk of life
whether you're a single 30 year old just
looking to sharpen your mind a 25 year
old who's out of college looking to make
new friends mom and dad who want to
connect with their kids better people
coming out of abusive relationships
everyone all of you have a story all of
you have a past
and we gave out some advanced copies of
this book recently to some listeners and
the reviews were just man it was
heartwarming the feedback we've seen for
this book it's life-changing so we've
taught god's and grandma's ways of
handling money for 30 years now and our
friend dr john he's paving the way for
how we talk about relationships and
mental health in the same way it's a
super complex topic and he has
simplified it so anyone can understand
it and take real steps towards improving
their mental health and their
relationships so go pre-order your copy
today while you still can for just 20
bucks because you're gonna get a bunch
of bonus items
including the audiobook version read by
john himself the ebook version and get
this one month of free weekly therapy
sessions from our friends over at
betterhelp that's an amazing deal for 20
bucks so go get your copy ramsay
solutions.com
all right let's go to the phones eric
joins us up next in kansas city eric
welcome to the ramsay show
hey thanks for taking my call absolutely
what's going on in your world
so my question for you is um i always
i've always heard dave say we should
never take a job that pays less than
you're currently making
so my question is is there an exception
to that rule and is it worth taking a
pay cut for your dream job
i don't know that i've heard him give
that kind of advice consistently that
you should never take a pay cut ever oh
now uh if you're listening to my friend
ken coleman he would say why can't we do
the dream job and get paid well for
doing it i think that's the goal but
what's your situation currently
the current situation is i'm taking home
about uh 62 thousand and i i'm working
in manufacturing
i have a degree in criminal justice
which i used for a few years but then
when i was given the manufacturing
opportunity it was paying a lot more so
it made sense for me to take that job so
you saw the dollar sign
i can make more over here
exactly
but now i'm getting really bored with it
and kind of frustrated with some things
going on at work and i was given an
opportunity to pursue my
uh criminal justice degree in in that
field and it would be about a ten
thousand dollar paycheck
so i'm just trying to decide what to do
and uh
have to give you guys a call
so can you afford all of your bills if
you had a ten thousand dollar pay cut
yes
the only that we have is mortgage okay
okay so this is you and your
wife yeah okay a little eight month old
oh that's sweet
well here's the deal i think that you
can make up for this income
pretty quickly especially if you're
passionate about it you're going to be
even better at it so what is this job
that you'd be taking
uh law enforcement okay
so this is starting salary essentially
you've never done this kind of work
before
uh correct okay
well listen man if i'm in your shoes in
your financial situation i'm gonna take
it and then i'm gonna work my tail off
to get the income back to where it was
and even higher
and a year from now two years from now
you're gonna look back and go man i'm
making 50 60 70 now
because i really put the time in and i
love the work i'm doing so i'm okay with
you taking this uh this pay cut
temporarily knowing that we're gonna get
this thing back up to where it was
okay that makes sense
and when you look at it this way the
reason you followed this plan the ramsey
plan is to have
options is to have freedom is to have
meaning and that's what this has done
for you because you don't have a lot of
debt you just have the mortgage right
right and you have a fully funded
emergency fund
yes you got financial peace man and when
you have financial peace you can take a
tiny step like you're taking right now
into that job and not worry too much
about it so i'd encourage you to call in
to ken coleman show i'm curious to hear
uh his thoughts but i think he would say
the same thing let's get this income
back up and even higher than where it
was but temporarily
i'm okay with this if you've got this
opportunity to step into law enforcement
which is what you told me you love to do
yeah that makes sense i appreciate it
yeah man thanks so much for the call
awesome loved you taking that leap all
right zach is joining us up next he's in
west palm beach what's up zack
hey what's up george big fan so here's
my problem i really want to be debt-free
and over the last couple years i've been
aggressively paying off my house uh in
december of 2020 paid it off i own it
free and clear but then i screwed up i
screwed up uh dave would be very upset
with me because the next day i went out
and i bought a tesla and i financed it
over
over 72 months uh the loan in the
beginning was 54 000 i've been paying
810 a month uh for the last year and a
half and i'm at a point you know i have
a fully funded emergency fund i have a
good amount of money in my retirement my
house is paid off i have a good income
definitely uh have financial peace um
but i want to know if i should work on
aggressively paying off my car or if i
should invest that money in the stock
market no we are paying off this car man
listen i i love both of those things i
love you paying off the car and i love
you investing in the stock market but
we've got to do one thing at a time here
so how much liquid cash do you have to
your name well i have about 15 000 in an
emergency fund and then i got about
another 25
30 000
so you know i could pay it off but then
it would leave me very little cash um
but you know i could make large payments
over time which is what i would feel
more comfortable doing but if i don't
know i'm just i'm lost and i can i need
some guidance okay well when i'm lost i
like to to follow the path
uh and so the ramsey solutions baby
steps is the path i want you to follow
and it starts with baby step one a
thousand dollars emergency fund you have
that now here's the scary news baby step
two we're paying off all the debt using
the debt snowball this is your only debt
you've got 43 000 left on the car what's
left
yeah exactly 43 000 left on the car and
so we're gonna pay this thing off and
that means everything but the thousand
we're gonna throw at the car
does that scare you a little bit
yeah that does scare me you know what
scares me making 810 payments every
month
i know i i know dude you work too hard
to be this broke what's your household
income you're right uh it varies uh i'm
a real estate agent got a couple other
businesses so income is very
inconsistent but it's about
uh eight to ten thousand dollars a month
take home okay fantastic so we're making
six figures you almost have the cash on
hand to pay this off today
just about might be a couple thousand
short okay
well if i'm in your shoes you're gonna
build up that emergency fund really
quickly once you don't have an 810
payment in your life anymore
and so that's what i'm doing man i'm
going down to a thousand everything else
gets thrown into this car debt and next
month you're paying it off and once that
thing's paid off you're gonna build up
that savings account back up to where it
was very very quickly
yeah and you're not paying interest to a
lender helping them get rich
you are absolutely right because i'm
paying 80 to 100 a month in interest but
here's here's what's stopping you can i
tell you what's stopping you sure
so what's stopping me is when i play
around with the investment calculator on
dave's website ramseysolution.com i
always play around with that retirement
calculator i think it's great um when i
when i when i put 43 000 in a retirement
account and if i just get six percent on
that 43 000 over 30 years it ends up
being 246 000. if i get 8
if i get eight percent on forty three
thousand dollars over thirty years it's
four hundred and thirty two thousand
dollars and at ten percent it's 750k and
i'm like why would i put that forty
three thousand dollars into a car when i
could put it in my separate array
exactly the hilarious part is you are
right
and you're going to be even more right
when you take that 810 car payment and
invest that into the market
so let's not play games here let's not
do backwards math
if your logic is true then you want a
hundred percent of your income that you
can going into the market and right now
you can't do that because you owe a car
payment so let's get this debt cleaned
up like tomorrow dude you can do this
and throw 100 out your tesla every time
you drive it because that's what you're
doing with this interest man and that
thing goes fast let me tell you that
hundred dollars will go real quick in
the rear view mirror you got this dude
pay off the debt going back do your
debt-free scream that'll be fun love it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsay personality george campbell
taking your calls today about life and
money triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number to call
so over the last few days maybe weeks
now we've been talking about how to
combat inflation and protect your four
walls and our team here at ramsey
solutions published a great blog article
that you can check out at
ramseysolutions.com
all about just that how to combat
inflation and protect your four walls
the four walls that we talk about around
here are food utilities housing and
transportation so i've covered some
quick tips on the first three food
utilities and housing and i wanted to
just quickly talk about transportation
give you guys some hope some
encouragement some tips to save in those
areas as inflation keeps getting crazier
and crazier so let's talk about this
as you know the average price of a
gallon of gas has skyrocketed here in
tennessee it's uh well over four bucks
probably higher where you are
and so let's talk about gas real quick
gas rewards and cash back programs can
be some good options for you right now
we've got a gross grocery store called
kroger here and they've got some rewards
programs if you're already buying your
groceries or you're not even buying
anything i get three cents off every
gallon not gonna change your life but
hey every little bit helps and there's
some great cash back apps out there like
get upside and gas buddy that can show
you deals around your area and give you
cash back for the gas that you're
already getting
and speaking of gas buddy that's one of
my favorite apps to track the cheapest
gas prices the cheapest gas is not
always at my local wholesale club like
costco or sam's club sometimes it's at
the the local shell down the street and
so you can use gas buddy or waze to find
the cheapest gas prices in your area
some great apps to have there on your
phone some other ways that you may not
have thought about uh make less trips
that's right make one trip instead of
seven if you've got some errands to run
just plan better people that's all i'm
asking you to do
and carpool america's favorite pastime
carpooling that's right great way to
have some human connection while saving
some money whether it's to the office uh
to school with the kids kids soccer game
whatever you got going on figure out a
way to have less cars on the road less
gas being purchased
now when it comes to transportation we
got to talk about car prices the car
market is still pretty wild out there
i'm hoping for good things to be
happening sometime soon but let's talk
about some ways to save on cars number
one the best way to save just don't buy
a car right now
i don't know why but it's like when the
car market goes crazy we all want to go
out and get a car
so let's just slow down and go do we
actually need a car if the answer is no
i wouldn't be buying a car right now
that's it so if your car is working it
gets you from a to b let's just take a
chill pill
number two shop around for auto
insurance rates this one is huge you
just have had your auto insurance for
years and years and years you haven't
shopped around
and that can free up you know 30 40 50
bucks in your budget every month when
you realize you're not getting that
great of a deal
so check out our friends at xander
insurance you can go to ramsey
solutions.com we can help you shop
around all of the best auto insurance
companies to get you the best deal on
those premiums
and carpools co-workers we mentioned
this but this is another way that you
can get around some of the craziness is
uh carpooling you know here ramsay
solutions we have over a thousand team
members james lives nearby kelly you
know maybe a carpool to save some money
on gas for a little while and of course
sharing a car if you've got a second car
maybe you and your spouse share one for
a little while that can be a huge help
and lastly if you do have to get a car
budget for it pay cash don't get ripped
off at this dealership
and i know out there they're gonna say
hey finance you'll save a thousand
dollars by uh financing with us you say
no thank you sir and you check that
contract out for the sale and you look
and see all of the different fees they
tacked on there and you say nope nope
not paying that not paying that i'm
walking away that's what you do i don't
want you to pay anything more than sales
tax and
maybe a small small doc fee
anything outside of that their premium
care their warranties avoid that like
the plague they are ripping you off so
find a reputable dealership maybe go
private sale and negotiate on facebook
marketplace or craigslist do what you
got to do but do not get ripped off
during these crazy times so there you go
that wraps our series on how to combat
inflation protect your four walls hope
that was helpful a lot of empathy for
you all out there dealing with this
trying to find the margin in your budget
which is what it comes down to how do we
spend less how do we make more how do we
have that margin so that we don't feel
the pinch of inflation
all right open phones this hour we're
headed to micah in albuquerque new
mexico next micah how's it going
hey i'm doing all right so
my question is i'm wondering if i should
sell my house um
situation right now is where me and my
wife are both 24 years old we uh we have
a gross
income of 70 000.
our house has 86 000 in equity but the
problem is we're very over extended on
bills um
right now our net income each month is
about forty seven hundred and
about forty two hundred of that is going
out to bills ouch now when you say bills
do you mean debt on the way in about
seven months and we're not going to be
able to
afford our bills when she goes on
maternity leave
so my question is um
does that seem like a viable option we
would be able to pay off all of our debt
and make things a lot easier on
ourselves
yeah i mean it's a last ditch option i
don't love the idea of just selling the
house as our first option but it can be
an option if you're willing to do that
and rent for a while and you've got some
equity in there you can clean up the
debt i mean this can be a great thing to
sacrifice to get yourself in a better
financial position
okay so when you say you have 4 200 what
kind of what kind of bills are these
that's all debt consumer debt
not all of it a good majority of it is i
have about 1200 in debt so mortgage is
1300 we have 700 dollars in car payments
um
and then i had to purchase some tires um
and that's 300 a month and that's that's
a big chunk 300 a month for tires
yeah do you own a monster truck
for the tires
so you're paying 300 bucks a month for
tires when is this thing paid off what's
the total amount owed
total amount owed right now is 1200 um
we did get pretty rough apr apr came out
to 18
um
and i believe we still have
about a year left on that because of the
interest rates you have a year left on
the tires
yeah to pay 1200 off you're paying 300 a
month
yeah yeah it's i might my brain hurts i
don't i don't think the math is right on
that but let's talk about your situation
here you asked should we sell the house
to get out of debt
you have how much that total what's the
total amount
total debt is 22 000. 22 000 in debt
and you bring home 4 700 a month
so correct what are the cars worth
so my car is worth 15 000 um and my
wife's car is worth 8 500. okay and
what's on the loans for those cars
her car we owe
um
2 800 left and on mine i just
i mean i made a bad decision i just
bought it
and so i owe 15 000 on it
well it looks like we're selling a car
before i sell the house you know
i mean that's a that's a big move to go
ahead and sell your house and i'm okay
with it but i don't want you to look at
this like it's some kind of leapfrogging
shortcut i mean this is a big deal
and so if we can avoid selling the house
and get out of this debt which you're
telling me if you sold the car
you would then be down to seven thousand
dollars of total debt
um yes correct and you're thinking it's
worth it to sell a house to get out of
seven thousand dollars
well yeah my thinking was if i sell the
car that'll say this car that i just got
it'll save us 500 a month
um so our bills would go down to 3 700.
i just don't think this is that dire of
a situation you're not 200 thousand
dollars in debt here sell the car we're
gonna get a beater save up some cash get
a beater car if you have to sell your
wife's car too and you get two beaters
i'm okay with that if it means avoiding
selling the house
okay cause you're gonna go have to rent
the top of the market in albuquerque
right
right yeah which is going to be higher
than what you're paying right now in the
1300 a month on the mortgage
so i think this seems like a better
solution in your head but on paper it
doesn't make sense so
man i'm i'm in your shoes i'm selling
both cars i'm getting beater cars
with what's left that you have in cash
and then we're going to attack the rest
of the debt which is going to be what
close to 5 000 at that point making 4
700 a month take home and now you freed
up those car payments
you can do this man just follow the baby
steps one by one focused intensity you
can do this without having to sell your
home and rent at the top of the market
we're rooting for you man let me know if
i can help in any other way this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
hebrews 4 16.
let us then approach god's throne of
grace with confidence so that we may
receive mercy
and find grace to help us in our time of
need
stephen covey said effective people are
not problem minded they're
opportunity-minded they feed
opportunities and starve problems
good stuff
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com their 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color they'll remake
your blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run
every month you're gonna save even more
you can use the promo code ramsey to get
the best deal today's question comes
from jacqueline in michigan she says i'm
in baby step 2 currently and i have
about 28 000 student loan debt to pay
off i have no other consumer debt i'm 30
years old and would love to purchase a
house in the next few years once my dad
is paid however i'm terrified of going
into debt again with a mortgage what's
some advice for a first-time homebuyer
who is scared of the additional debt of
a mortgage
well jacqueline i love that you've got
some pause about this and you don't see
this as monopoly money which is how a
lot of people see debt they just go well
what's five hundred thousand dollars of
student loan debt what's 500 000 of a
mortgage
but i will say that a mortgage debt is
is going to be very different than a
student loan debt
with student loans you're kind of paying
for the past you're not really building
for the future and the one nice thing
about mortgage debt is
you have an asset you have a home it's
going to appreciate it's going to build
in value you're going to own it once
it's paid off versus your student loans
i guess you own that piece of paper once
it's paid off good for you
so to your point i'm gonna pay off all
my student loan debt
i'm then gonna build my emergency fund
up to three to six months of expenses
and then i'm gonna focus on baby step
three b which is saving up for that down
payment
and the best way to avoid this being a
frightening experience where you have
regret and remorse and you're losing
sleep at night is for this home to be a
blessing
and not a curse
that means we're going to take the
patience we're going to save up 10 to 20
down
15-year fixed rate mortgage is the only
one a 30-year mortgage is a coffin i
mean you're 30 years old i don't want
you to be 60 still paying this thing off
so we're going to get 10 to 20 save down
or more we're gonna get a 15-year fixed
rate mortgage and i want the payment to
be no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay so you can jump onto
ramseysolutions.com use the mortgage
calculator and start to figure out what
that looks like for you in your area in
michigan for a reasonable home
if that means you need to put a whole
lot more money down in order to afford
the payment to where it's a quarter of
your take-home pay i'm okay with that it
means we have some patience we're going
to keep saving but that's truly the best
way if you're scared of additional debt
is to make it such a reasonable payment
that you have margin left over and this
mortgage is not causing you to have
financial ruin and so that's the way i
would do it that's the way i have done
it and i've got a paid for house now and
let me tell you
i have no fears when it comes to money
now i'm scared of like snakes and clowns
but mortgage debt i am no longer afraid
of so thank you so much for the question
all right let's go to eric he is in
chicago illinois eric welcome to the
ramsay show
hey george thanks for taking my call
absolutely what's going on with you how
can i help
i am calling today looking for probably
just a little reassurance my wife and i
we've had our quote-unquote grown-up
jobs for about 15 years now investing
in our company's 401ks okay but it
wasn't until i started listening to the
show that i realized
it's a little bit more complicated than
that with
match beating ira or yeah match beating
ira beating traditional
and so i'm basically just
sorry a little nervous
that's all right you're doing great man
i'm here for you
appreciate that uh basically just
looking for a little reassurance that
our
blind uh depositing of funds into our
just standard company 401ks
didn't doesn't have us missing out too
much on the future hmm
great question so yeah what we say is
that match beats roth beats traditional
match is free money it's 100 return on
your investment
if you put in 100 bucks they're going to
match 100 bucks right up to a certain
amount
followed by that we love tax-free growth
around here and so you're gonna use
after-tax dollars with a roth and then
you can withdraw it tax-free in
retirement
followed by that we move to traditional
which you're gonna pay taxes on when you
withdraw it but you don't pay taxes on
it now
so that's what that refers to so it
depends on your situation do you have a
roth option through your employer for
your 401k or is it just traditional
it's just a traditional 401k okay and
they do have a match
they do have a three percent match okay
so in this case we're going to take the
three percent match
in the 401k this is the first thing we
do
beyond that i would go to a roth ira to
our roth options and fully fund that
what's your household income
um
before tax 200 000 okay you're right
there on the cusp so look into the rules
for
this year
to make sure that you are still eligible
to
deposit money into that roth
because there are income limits with the
roth ira
okay but you should be right there at
the cusp you may be good so i'd fully
fund that
and beyond that i'm going back to the
traditional to finish out the fifteen
percent
okay so it's a good question to have a
plan yeah i would still look into it
make sure that you know your the numbers
are adding up here but get to that 15
you're doing the right things make sure
that you're invested in good growth
stock mutual funds inside of that 401k
because the 401k is just a shell so you
got to be investing in something in that
so make sure you're you're investing in
things with a proven track record
diversifying across the four types that
we talk about and you'll be just fine my
man
i appreciate the uh the reassurance
there i'm here for you you sound
confident you sound like you're walking
taller already all right let's move on
to kevin to close out the salaries in
denver kevin what's up
hey good afternoon how are you doing
great how can i help
well i have a a good problem but
nonetheless it's a serious problem i've
run into
i went through a divorce eight years ago
and had very little cash living in my
brother's basement
and um
parlayed what i
had taken from the divorce
into three properties and i just sold
one
okay well now i ha now i have 800 000
sitting there in a 1031 exchange wow
and i do not want to chase this real
estate market
um
now with the 1031 you're going to have
to roll it into another property
or pay a lot of capital gains tax i
don't like that option
i don't either i've talked to numerous
financial planners and stock brokers and
everybody has their own idea what to do
what's the general consensus
uh
for myself it's
pay the piper pay the tax what's the tax
implications here what are we talking
we're talking about two hundred thousand
of that eight hundred
so you'd be down to six hundred
correct and you're telling me i wanna be
out of the real estate game
i'm still in the real estate game with a
rental property and the property i live
in
and i could pay those two properties off
and be debt-free
and
or i'm 63 and
it's either get out of debt or go into
some type of insurance plan or annuities
to create
retirement income in the next few years
and that's the dilemma
yeah i mean you could have some cash
flowing properties that are paid off as
part of your retirement strategy
and you could invest any difference into
a taxable brokerage account you can do
some catch-up contributions with other
tax advantage retirement accounts but
there's a lot of complex things going on
here have you worked with a good
reputable financial advisor that you
like or they're all giving you different
advice
i have there's two certified financial
planners i've been working with and they
do not know each other and each one of
them gave me almost identical plans what
was that
half the money would go into a
uh annuity with either immediate
residual income or i could postpone the
income until i retire
the other 50 of the money would go into
a
indexed
life plan
which in five years i could withdraw
money from tax free
man there's so many fees involved with
all this and it sounds like the
financial advisors are the ones winning
i would get in touch with the
smartvestor pro get a third opinion you
can do that at ramseysolutions.com
i want you to make an educated decision
here there's a lot of zeros on the end
of this and so i think you're wise to
take your time move slow and make the
right decision when you feel good about
it that's the important part thanks for
the call man that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books my thanks to
all the folks in the booth making the
show happen today and you america we
appreciate you listening in we'll be
back with you before you know it
remember spend wisely save intentionally
and give generously this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
you